shocking video out of California shows a
Brazen shoplifter ransacking the shells
of a 7-Eleven the thief allegedly
threatened to shoot the workers when
they verbally confronted him and that's
when two employees were forced to step
in and take him down
viewer warning this video is a little
graphic
ain't nothing you can do man tell police
come in
hey no hey don't hey man don't do that
hey man don't do that
you know no more no more come here right
I have no idea a bystander says the
workers then led the thief out of the
store ordering him to never come back
again and now in Chicago the mayor there
defended a swarm of teens who looted and
destroyed a convenience store the mayor
insisting it was just a large Gathering
we're not talking about mob actions I
didn't say that these large gatherings
these large Gatherings just hold on a
second y'all I promise you we have time
to talk it's important that we speak of
these Dynamics in an appropriate way
this is not to obfuscate what is
actually taking place I mean to refer to
children as like Baby Al Capone's is not
appropriate
Chicago Police later arrested 40 of the
alleged participants Dana we've talked
about the issue of crime a long time
here and I I mean obvious we all want
constructive Solutions but one of that
one of those Solutions has to be
arresting people Prosecuting people and
keeping them in jail if they are doing
better this is like the fourth story
I've seen today where somebody is a
victim of a crime and they know the
police aren't going to make it in time
or they're not enough police the other
one was in Portland I saw that but the
woman that woman was on earlier today
and I don't know exactly if these guys
own this franchise but 7-Eleven you have
a franchise and so imagine how hard
those people who work there have
scrimped and saved and they're trying to
live the American dream and they're
going to get ripped off by this guy and
they know the cops aren't going to come
and if they do there's no recall and so
one of the things I remember Lawrence
Jones has been talking about for a long
time on cross country and on other
places where he's been reporting all
around the nation is that
unfortunately some people are going to
want to take matters into their own
hands and they might call it vid some
might call it vigilante justice but the
other hand is saying but this is my
livelihood this is my business this is
my and this is wrong stealing is wrong
and somebody's got to do something about
it we have a Subway situation here with
young Mr penny in New York we had a
situation with the bodega owner who
attacked who got who almost was a was
prosecuted how do you feel about this
correct um there's no you no one has a
reason to defend this guy for what he
did he should be saluted I for one
salute the stick it works better than
the carrot uh what politicians and
bureaucrats do not understand the power
and fury that arises from hopelessness
you know we were in my neighborhood when
New York was looted without any
resistance de Blasio pulled back the
police my beloved Hood was ruined for
months so I understand the man with this
stick I wanted to be the man with this
stick unfortunately I can't be the man
with the stick but all politicians do is
throw carrots out there and now it's
time for the stick and that's not
vigilanteism that is Justice I've
watched that video a lot you know it's
therapeutic and I also read that I also
read the comments every single person
felt good about it does that make them
bad no if you think that's bad you're
the ass because you're the one that
defends that kind of criminal the people
that feel good is because they're so
tired of seeing the same old Story the
person that works really hard getting
beaten up by a mob and then the Mayors
and the bureaucrats the defending the
mob so what you get that's something I
wouldn't even say it's workers Revenge
that is Justice because they can't get
it anywhere else and I hope that that
guy when he left that store spread the
word I can't you don't go to that store
do not go to that store and by the way
you know what that the other guy was
saying dude don't do anything man the
insurance will take care of it that's
how the system is corruptable the system
tells you insurance will take care of it
the thugs know that so there is a
corrupt system for you how do we get
more cops on the street
well you have to create an environment
where people want to be cops right now
you guys have destroyed that and when I
say you guys I don't mean you personally
Harold but it's easier to talk like that
if you see Democrats yeah obviously if
7-Eleven fires this guy he has a job on
Jesse Waters prime time I don't care if
he can't cut tape or doesn't even know
who Trump is he has a job and health
insurance on my show I think everyone
should have a stick that size yes he
went Teddy Roosevelt on him speak softly
and carry a big stick if you want to
pull out a pistol that stick was very
very effective it bruises it might leave
a welt maybe draws blood but that's the
perfect weapon for a convenience store
defense okay now if you want Cops to be
cops let them be cops but these store
owners now know you have to sit around
and watch yeah who is going to sit and
watch your store get jacked no one is
going to do that sometimes men need to
settle things like men and that's fine
by me how do we get a better balance
Jesse's right the police and people how
people say police or do we just what do
we do why would you as a young person or
any person want to be recruited as a
police officer they have first of all
there's defunding so they're funding
issues in some places but there's also
recruiting if you know you're going to
go risk your life for not a super great
paycheck for people who don't appreciate
you um when they've been disparaged in
so many places just recruiting is going
to be hard to get people out there but
to the point about insurance you talk to
business owners and they will say it
does not begin to cover the damage all
the the time that they're out of off out
of work that they have to close down all
kinds of things I mean there's so many
repercussions here you can understand
why people get so frustrated we don't
want that to happen but I understand it
Harold might I add that tonight on my
show I will be playing that entire video
and I will not be blurring the man's
butt crack
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now